what is uh so the Grammys just got uh
wrapped up uh
Harry Styles phenomenal here
for you what was your favorite album
okay I don't even want to go Grammy
cycle because it's a little confusing to
remember what came out from September to
September but what was your favorite
album last year my favorite album last
year I like underground like artists not
even underground but like Brent fires
Brent fires almost crazy toxic as hell I
played that out very toxic album I
love it yes
um so for me that was my top album you
know
and I don't mean to say underground but
I love like you know people that aren't
may not be on the radio 24 7. right so
those are friends he's a beast his band
is crazy too super crazy pain what about
on the hip-hop side
um hip-hop side
and it might have been a light year for
for rep I mean yeah there was some good
there was like uh Kendrick Pusha T
okay okay what else was dope last year
future okay
future damn near rbr is now like wait
for you it's like a brilliant r b record
I fear you
but yeah I'm so locked down RMV I guess
I didn't really turn into much much yeah
I've been going through it so okay the
guy who won best r b album that Chris
Brown did not know who he was did you
know who he was I didn't know who he was
at all okay but
you know did you leave yeah some someone
knows though someone knows yeah
but I do feel like Chris deserved
he deserves listen
I think Chris Brown is probably him or
Jamie Foxx in terms of just talent in
one body yeah
the most talented in the
world
because like Chris Brown Can Dance you
can sing he can paint an Entertainer he
could uh he could play
basketball I just mean Talent I'm not
even tomorrow just everything yeah and
then you got Jamie Foxx who could do
stand-up he can act he can that's crazy
he is a comedian as well those two are
like the two unicorns if we're just
talking about raw talent
Chris Brown's like I feel like I feel
like sometimes we don't appreciate Chris
enough absolutely I do feel like he's
he's like the closest
we have to Mike he's our mic he's our
mic for sure
so yeah to see somebody else win like
that he did break break our hearts you
know I felt I felt Chris on that and
Chris Brown's almost hard it was I mean
look not I don't even like the other guy
I didn't listen to his album so I I
could be better and that's the thing I
hadn't heard heard of it um I didn't
listen to Harry Styles that's why the
Grammys you know we got to be careful
giving you know give any award shows too
much
well you know what they did this year
they realized nobody was watching so
they just made that hip hop as
right I heard they had a hip-hop tribute
it was not just that it was like the
whole show ended with like Jay-Z rapping
out of the Last Supper when DJ Khaled
little baby did freestyle at the Grammys
this is amazing it was amazing well I'm
glad to hear that though we do need more
you know just more involvement I don't
want to up his name I think it's
Jesse Collins the guy who produced the
Grammys but he's the guy who always
disapp who's been doing the BET Awards
the last few years so they had to kind
of tap in because and then and people
were talking about the Grammys in a
positive way this year yeah but that's
the thing you know rap really influences
everything so you know if you want
people to tune in you gotta you gotta
balance it out yeah for sure